vegas this weekend yeah so dirty heads
they're one of the hottest reggae rock
bands in the country these guys are
incredible they're performing at the
downtown las vegas event center tomorrow
night and earlier today i spoke with the
lead singer jared dirty j
watson take a look
[Music]
jared welcome to the show buddy and i
think i need to welcome a very special
guest with us who do you have there with
you this is aisle watson he's my uh he's
my new manager
i'm gonna handle everything from now on
he's closing all the deals for he booked
the vegas gig exactly
how old is he
four months old is this his first
television interview this is his first
interview yeah he's pretty nervous
he'll do just fine he'll do just fine
you're a yearwood huntington beach
california guy born and raised yes yes
sir we would you surf as a kid and is
your son going to be a surfer
see i definitely grew up surfing and in
the water and like still circle lots one
of my bigger hobbies you know i try and
get my daughter to surf
but i also don't want to be the football
dad and like push him into it and then
have them not like it so i'm just gonna
like see where it goes you know
and then i i think i just asked the
silliest question ever i'm like are you
a surfer and there's literally like 10
surfboards right behind you pretty
excited my wife let me put my surfboards
inside
oh that's honestly your daughter too
they're in the background this is the
family man this
is she was supposed to be outside but
she's cruising
hey
[Applause]
i'm on vacation every single day every
every single day
[Music]
i want to talk about the song vacation
because you guys go viral over this
whole thing but what was that like when
your song goes viral there's a tick tock
challenge kind of goes along with the
whole thing what was that like for you
guys
it was a trip you know because it was
organic we had nothing to do with it
right like we were just sitting at home
like kind of twiddling our thumbs next
thing you know i'm like getting calls
from younger friends of mine the label
management like hey you know
vacation is blowing up on tick tock and
i'm like cool i don't you know i don't
have a tick tock like what's going on
um and there was just yeah this viral
like little challenge and it kind of
blew up and within i think
you know six months to a year that song
went platinum
[Applause]
[Music]
so one of your more recent singles is
you guys covered joe washer's song
life's been good did you have to get his
permission to to sample and cover his
song and has he heard it and said
anything about it yeah we uh 100 got it
cleared and you got to get it cleared
you know because if we just covered it
straight i don't think you have to get
it cleared but the fact that we just
took a small part changed the lyrics
changed the music and then did our own
verses and we kind of like took it from
a hip-hop standpoint like almost sampled
it and then you know did our own stuff
um we had to get it cleared and joe
heard it and said he loved it that's
awesome man we're excited to have you
guys here in in town in vegas tomorrow
night is the entire family coming baby
daughter everyone coming with you
no they'll chill at home we got 10 days
left so they'll hang out well i think
vegas will be accepting of you if you
came out with your baby on stage and
saying a couple songs they'd be cool
with it but totally understand the uh
perfect place for baby like i'll just
come out the hangover strap yes yes
ah he's funny he's a great guy yeah the
dirty heads let's get a crack in 2020
towards happening tomorrow at the
downtown las vegas event center for
tickets go to reggaeriseup.com